hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer so my
friends are tasty japan
introduce me at mara daigaku this giant
gomadango which is a crispy fried sesame
coated mochi ball the restaurant was
kind enough to teach me how to make it
but here's a catch they can only
introduce me the technique but the
recipe has to be kept a secret and i
will only have one chance to make it
i've also been informed that there is
only one chef at the restaurant that
knows how to make it so it seems like it
will be very challenging but let's see
how i do
so i'm a mara daigaku and this is chef
ra he's going to teach me the technique
of how to make giant rice ball but
here's the thing he only speaks chinese
i don't speak chinese and see we're
gonna be a best friend after this
let's do it okay
so the the temperature is quite low than
i expected so he's shaking in a
giant block so he just told me
temperature is 80 to 90
celsius he said
temperature is very important and make
sure keeping the perfect round shape
[Laughter]
if the best chef makes mistake that
makes me feel a little better
so what i notice is the bowl is
big and also it's already warm i think
that's the important part
he's using two tools one is colander and
one is huge little and pouring a little
bit
oil around it so i think um first one
was too brown too quickly from starting
point on right now it's only
took like three minutes so it's
happening quite quickly
[Laughter]
oh my god
do you think i can do this
of course
what did i sign up for so i just asked
him when do you know it's done and he
said when it's nice golden brown
he knows it's ready
[Music]
[Laughter]
did you see his face
no no no okay no no no no
[Music]
so we are checking temperature like kind
of touching on the surface of the oil
it's kind of hot and nice so i think we
are ready
you have to like
rotate i think
i think it's so difficult like it has to
be like
that okay
so he helped me in the beginning so it's
become round and it's more like a baron
than the ball so it's easier to
it's so difficult so he's kind of
rotating like all the way around
and it's just difficult to
like spin like that
i
it's a little easier that it's all a
little difficult because it's bigger now
i don't know what's what i'm doing
it's kind of like a beach balloon
floating on the surface
my
mind's different
oh no
it's so difficult
look he makes my mistake
thank you
he's kind of picking
one side and rotating like that
it's very difficult to spin in this huge
thing in oil and it's hot so you are
kind of scared
and you have to also splash the oil when
you are like spinning
look how small mine and like not
not pretty
[Music]
i wasn't able to do it by myself i got a
lot of help from chef ra so to be honest
i didn't think i was able to do it just
one shot let alone
one day
or a month
chef ryan is a master of his craft
and it requires a lot of practice and
this makes me respect all the chefs and
craftsmen make difficult things look
easy i have more appreciation for this
dish and most importantly chef vlad and
i are bffs
[Music]
you